here we go last little quick intro piece
this is the third of the comic books
that I believe should be turned into
movies but probably won't which brings
me to the one more than any I want to
see this one made probably never gonna
have them but this is the one I really
want trans metropolitan to try and
describe this book and this character
spider Jerusalem to anyone who hasn't
read it imagine if Hunter s Thompson
lived in the world of Blade Runner and
you're pretty much there spider is a
journalist and he is a despicable human
being he is a massive drug abuser he is
violent as heck he's misogynistic he
hates people to a degree that is simply
epic but he also has a clear unwavering
devotion to finding out and reporting
the truth now that's pretty much
literally his only virtue he doesn't
even have to face the faith in his
readers that they would do anything
useful with the truth he's giving them
but he's still gonna find it he's still
gonna put it out there and this book is
so first of all funny it's incredibly
funny from start to finish it is a riot
but it's also really cutting there's a
lot of commentary in this editing it's
not subtle commentary but it still hits
pretty darn close to home usually with a
wicked sense of humor at every step now
the reason that this probably is never
going to get made this has to be rated R
you could do Sandman pg-13 you could do
Farwest pg-13 and generally when you're
doing comic book movies you kind of have
to do pg-13 because you need that wider
audience pool to offset the cost of
these things because they're expensive
this has to be are actually this has to
be borderline nc-17 you cannot water
down this character because if you do
you have betrayed absolutely everything
that this comic book and this character
is about he has to remain raw he has to
be swearing in every single sentence he
has to be
the crap out of people who looked at him
the wrong way you cannot tone it down
already comic-book movies the most
successful one from Strictly box-office
then point was Watchmen before that he
had the Blade movies but sad the horror
thing going with him which is its own
thing unto itself another than that what
have we had we had Punisher war zone
there's not a lot of faith in our ad
comic book movies you know kickass is
doing okay but this is gonna be more
expensive than kick-ass is you have to
create that sort of futuristic but not
completely off the charts it needs to be
familiar but still have all the ramped
up technology it's not gonna be cheap to
do and because it's not gonna be cheap
nobody's ever gonna put the money behind
us and people have tried Patrick Stewart
huge fan of this tried to get this thing
going with himself to start about a
decade ago and if he could have gotten
it off the ground would have been
brilliant honestly as much as I love
Patrick Stewart he's too old for the
part now but this still should get made
I want to see a trailer for Spider
Jerusalem screams at the top of his
lungs at the audience to go [ __ ]
themselves and gives them all the finger
that is the movie I want to see and
there you go those those are three comic
books that I think could really cleanly
translate to film and probably never
will on that slightly down note this
council is a jerk